in Middle Earth shadow of Mordor you are
tallying a ranger of Gondor guarding of
a black gates until the night siren on
his black captain's returned to Mordor
killing everyone you've ever loved
leaving you for dead this walkthrough
takes place several hours into the game
and focuses on the Nemesis system the
next-gen living world which creates
unique personal enemies on every
playthrough in this instance Italians
mission is to kill the Uruk war chief or
thug and in order to get to him
Talia is going to hunt down one of his
henchmen an aura captain called ratbag
who telling us track to this village
like every enemy you face in the Nemesis
system red bag and northug are
completely unique to this gameplay
instance there are no generic and
enemies within this dynamic living world
every interaction between talia and his
enemies has a direct effect on direct
society ratbag has already met time and
survived and his unique personality has
evolved to shape this gameplay encounter
he's now been promoted to a new job as a
slaver which is why we can find him in
this village persecuting the humans
below Tanya's quest for vengeance is
aided by a mysterious undying spirit a
wraith this wraith transforms tell you
and gives him the power to pursue his
enemies into Mordor and it enables him
to move between the physical world and
the Wraith world
the world we see when Bilbo and Frodo
put on the One Ring in the Wraith world
telling you can identify his enemies
such as ratbag and returned to the
railroad to confront them very walk ha
you left my master to burn so I'm gonna
cut his show and savor every Jewish
memory is an important feature of the
Nemesis system and right back is never
going to forget that he only just
survived his last fight with Talia this
unique combination of personality in
history
make him distinct from every other enemy
Talia needs
he's a coward it hurt he's gonna run as
soon as the odds turn against them
Mossad obey
again time but his rate showers two
years one of the key powers of a wraith
is the ability to dominate their enemies
through terror bend them to your will
you will obey
now ratbag is tele ins meaning he can be
ordered to spy feedback information to
spread terror by carrying the message of
what he's witnessed here to build tally
ins legend among surrounds forces or to
be sent on a mission to assassinate his
leader each choice creates a unique
mission in the open world of Mordor
re-entering ratbags mind tallien can see
his relationship with the other who Rock
leaders as well as their unique
characteristics and abilities ratbags
master and the war chief in this area is
worth OGG who was also had a previous
encounter with tallian in his case a
battle which left him severely scarred
on the face or thug is very different to
right back
he's extremely tough on his many
followers right back has almost no
chance of killing him
but by creating an assassination mission
Italian gains the opportunity to follow
ratbag and finish off his enemy himself
in the open world Tania can begin the
mission at any time but this walkthrough
will fast forward to the assassination
attempt plain as tallien opens up a
world of creative choice about how to
approach every mission in this case the
cover of night and the rain creates a
range of opportunities use bait to draw
in trolls and Kara Gore's to create a
distraction take a direct combat
approach or use a stealth approach to
infiltrate get as close to Talia's
target as possible again Tania moves
into the Wraith world to identify or
thug who's called this meeting ratbag
was behind where thug can be recognized
by the blue hand indicating his talons
minion we can also see ratbag supporters
it could be recognized by white hands
since Talia now dominates ratbag he also
controls his followers allowing tallien
to build his forces behind enemy lines
four additional fire support tallying is
going to dominate the surgery so now
each borrower can be triggered
individually as part of a tactical
approach or at once to cause in fighting
chaos will obey distraction so Talia can
finish off of red bags thirds
we tried us pale white blood banks
attacks severely damages or thought and
although he is of Italian now has a
major advantage going into bout that
you left me to burn I'm gonna make you
pay my light through the Nemesis system
or thought remembers this previous
encounter Italian making this battle
both unique and
you burn my face when I will burn your
thoughts
RAAA
my car
yeah
tell your master carry back to Sauron
when he comes for us our pawns will be
in place and all mortal Wilbur